hello and welcome to lesson four of the
business analytics foundation with our
tools course offered by simplelearn
after completing this course you will be
able to
understand regression analysis and types
of regression models
know and build a simple linear
regression model
understand and develop a logistic
learn cluster analysis types and methods
to form clusters
no time series and its components
decompose seasonal and non-seasonal time
series
understand different exponential
smoothing methods
know the advantages and disadvantages of
exponential smoothing
understand the concepts of white noise
and corellogram
apply different time series analysis
like
box jenkins
ar
m a
arma etc
understand all the analysis techniques
with case studies
let's start our lesson with an
introduction to regression analysis
regression analysis focuses on finding a
relationship between a dependent
variable and one or more independent
variables
regression analysis predicts the value
of a dependent variable based on the
values of at least one independent
variable
the coefficients help in explaining how
the changes occurring in an independent
variable affect the dependent variable
regression analysis models can generally
be denoted by the following equation
y
is a function of x
comma beta
where the dependent variable that is the
variable that we want to explain is
denoted by y
the independent variable or the
explanatory variable is denoted by x
and beta is the unknown coefficient
regression analysis is widely used in
prediction and forecasting
in the next slide we will look at the
different types of regression models
in this slide we see a hierarchical
representation of the types of
regression models
the regression models are primarily
classified into two categories
univariate and multivariate models
univariate models the response variable
is affected by just one predictor
variable
it is the simplest form of statistical
analysis
correspondingly the multivariate models
refer to models where the response
variable is affected by more than one
predictor variables
the univariate and multivariate models
can be further classified to linear and
non-linear models
in the linear models the model is fitted
with a straight line
else is considered as non-linear model
the univariate linear regression is
further divided into simple and multiple
usually more than one independent
variable have an influence on the
dependent variable
when one independent variable is used in
a regression it is called a simple
regression
when two or more independent variables
are used it is called a multiple
regression
in the next slide we will look at simple
linear regression in detail
simple linear regression is a common
technique to determine how one variable
of interest is affected by another
it is used for three main purposes
for describing the linear dependence of
one variable on the other
for prediction of values of another
variable from the one which has more
data
correction of linear dependence of one
variable on the other
while building a simple linear
regression model a line is fitted
through the group of plotted data
the distance of the plotted points from
the line gives the residual value
the obtained residual value is a
discrepancy between the actual and the
predicted value
the procedure to find the best fitting
line for a group of data is called the
least squares method
it is based on the principle that the
sum of squared errors should be as
reduced as possible
so that the regression line has the
least error
in the next slide we will look at a
linear regression model
now
let's look at the regression equation in
detail
the equation that represents how an
independent variable is related to a
dependent variable
and an error term is a regression model
the equation is given by y equals to
beta naught plus beta 1 times x plus
epsilon
where beta naught and beta 1 are called
parameters of the model and epsilon is a
random variable called error term
getting the estimates of beta naught and
beta 1 that is e of y given x
means finding the best straight line
that can be drawn through the scatter
plot y versus x
this is done by the least square
estimates
in the next slide we will look at a
graphical explanation of the above
equation
the diagram here depicts a graphical
plotting of linear regression
the points in blue are the observed
values of y for the corresponding x
values
the straight line is the linear model
defined by the linear regression
equation seen in the previous slide
beta 1 is the slope of the equation
that is with one unit of change in x y
changes by beta 1.
if the value is positive it means that x
and y are positively correlated
and if it is negative then the two
variables are negatively correlated
beta naught is the value of y
at x equals zero
that is the intercept of the equation
the point of the straight line at x
equals x naught is the predicted value
of y at x equals x naught
the difference between the observed
value and the predicted value is the
residual or error term
in the next slide we will look at the
process in building a regression model
now let us look at the stepwise process
to build a regression model the first
step is identifying the target variables
that is the variables we are trying to
predict
the next step is identifying the
predictors
here we decide the variables that need
to be considered as a cause for the
target variable
then comes the data collection step
in data collection we collect data on
the predicted and the target variables
based on this data set we try to build a
model
next we decide the relationship
that is we now try to know what kind of
relationship may exist between the
target and the response variables
often simple data analysis and scatter
plot is done to identify this
then we fit the model we come to a
mathematical equation that is built to
help in predicting the response variable
finally we evaluate the model and check
for the efficiency of the fitted model
in predicting the outcome of the target
variables
in the next slide we will list out the
assumptions of a linear regression
models
linear regression model fitting requires
several assumptions being made to get
the best fit
they are listed here in this slide
the first assumption made is that the
predictor variable x
must be non-random
this means that there is no variance in
the measurement of the variable x
the next assumption is that the error
term epsilon is random
this makes y also random
hence for the same value of x we have
two different observations being made
each having a different value of y
and this happens due to the error term
error term follows normal distribution
with mean zero and standard deviation
sigma which is independent of x
the data being used to estimate the
parameters should be independent of each
other
if any of the above assumptions are
violated the modeling procedure must be
modified
in the next slide
we will look at the coefficient of
determination
the coefficient of determination denoted
by r squared is a measure of goodness of
fit
that is how well statistical models like
a line or curve fits the data
r squared is calculated in different
ways for different models
for a simple linear regression r squared
is calculated as the square of
correlation coefficient between the
observed and predicted values
we will now look at how different values
of r squared are interpreted
in the first figure the line is
perfectly horizontal
and the r squared is zero
which implies no linear relationship
in the second figure the r squared value
is negative one
implying a negative linear relationship
the last figure denotes a r-squared
value of plus one denoting a positive
linear relationship
in the next slide
we will look at ways to determine the
goodness of a model
once a model has been fitted how do we
use the value of r squared to know how
good the model is
based on the r squared value
we can explain how well the model
explains the data and the percentage of
differences that are explained by this
model
the differences between observations
that are not explained by the model is
the error term or residual
let us take an example to understand
this better
suppose we have a case in which r
squared value is 0.74
this means that 74 of variance in the
values of the independent variable is
explained by the model
the remaining 26 percent which is not
explained is its residual or error term
in the next slide we will look at an
example that illustrates the
calculations for fitting a linear
regression model to a sample data
let us now look at an example to
calculate the regression fit
in our example we will consider two
variables
age as x
and the corresponding glucose level as y
we are going to see how to make a linear
regression line for these variables
the general equation for regression
analysis is y
dash equals a plus b times
x in order to calculate this equation
manually we need to calculate three more
variables
x y
x squared and y squared values
then we calculate the sigma values by
summing up the values of x y
x y
x squared and y squared
here in order to derive the regression
equation we need to find the intercept a
value and coefficient of independent
value b
to calculate the value of intercept use
the formula a equal to sigma y squared
times of sigma x squared minus sigma x
times of sigma x y
the whole divided by n times of sigma x
squared minus sigma x the whole squared
by applying the corresponding value we
can obtain the intercept a value
the value of a that is obtained is
65.1416
then we need to calculate the
coefficient of dependent value b
in order to calculate this value use the
formula b equal to n times of sigma x y
minus sigma x times of sigma y the whole
divided by n times of sigma y
n times of sigma x squared minus sigma x
the whole squared
by applying the corresponding values we
obtain the b value as
0.3852
from this a and b value we can obtain
the final linear regression equation
that is y
dash equal to a plus bx
from the derived equation we can
calculate the future y dash value by
substituting the corresponding x value
in the next video we will look at the
commands to perform linear regression in
r
r provides comprehensive support for
linear regression
in order to perform linear regression
model and r
we need to use the lm function to fit
linear model
we will use r's inbuilt help to check on
the functionality of lm
the lm function carries out regression
single stratum analysis of variance and
analysis of covariance
this lm functionality contains various
arguments but we are going to see the
most frequently used arguments in
regression analysis
the formula argument is the object of
class formula which is a symbolic
description of the model to be fitted
data argument shows the data frame
containing the variables in the model
the formula in lm model is specified
using the
tilde symbol
the syntax is response tilde terms
where the response are the numeric
dependent vectors and the terms are
linear predictors or independent
variables for response
we can also use plus symbol to include
more predictor terms
lm model has various components in it
and two of the most essential components
are the coefficients and residuals
the coefficients provide the named
vector of coefficients and the residual
components provide the response minus
fitted values
now let us see how to draw the
regression line for a given data set
using r
the scatter plot is generally used to
plot the quantitative variables and
display them as geometric points inside
a cartesian diagram
to perform this let us take the faithful
data set which is already loaded by
default in r
the data set contains two variables
eruptions
and waiting
the eruption column specifies time of an
eruption in minutes and waiting
specifies the time between two eruptions
first let us make a scatter plot of
eruption durations and waiting intervals
and then try to find if there is any
relationship between the variables
we will now apply plot function to
compute the scatter plot of eruptions
and weighting
and name the x label and y label as
eruption duration and time weighted
respectively
the result plot shows that there is a
positive linear relationship between
eruption duration and time weighted
this depicts the fact that if time
weighted is high then the eruption
duration will also be higher
we can also generate a linear regression
model with the lm functionality and then
draw a trend line using a b line
functionality the syntax to perform this
regression model is
a b line of lm
with weighting as response variable and
duration as predictor term
the result plot shows the scatter plot
with the trend line being included and
this shows the positive linear
relationship between these two variables
eruption and weighting
in the next video we will use linear
regression to predict sales for an ice
cream company let's look at the case in
hand chip chops company is a global ice
cream manufacturing company specializing
in fruit and nut flavored ice creams
they have a very wide customer base
spanning almost all parts of the world
they want to find some useful insights
regarding individual and social consumer
consumption patterns so that they can
make changes to their business that may
yield them a higher consumption rate of
ice cream by individuals
they hired an r expert richard to work
on this situation and asked him to come
up with useful insights that in turn may
help their profitability and increase
consumer consumption rate
the data was readily available with the
company and the firm wanted richard to
work on a sample data and give them
insights before entrusting him with the
project
so now richard has a sample set of data
from the company and the data holds four
variables the first variable specifies
the consumption of ice cream per person
and it is a numeric variable
the second variable specifies the
average family income per week in us
dollars
the third variable tells about the price
of ice cream per unit
the fourth variable specifies the
average temperature that is experienced
in the city in terms of fahrenheit
the company's aim is to attract more
customers and increase the consumption
rate and ultimately increase their sales
and profit
to find this richard needs to find the
important factors that cause an impact
on the consumption rate in order to
define this relationship he wants to
perform a linear regression
this regression analysis would help us
in finding the relationship between the
factors and help us in predicting the
future consumer consumption rate in
regression analysis as we know there is
a dependent variable and various
independent variables
in our case we need to find the pattern
and consumption rate so it is being
declared as the dependent variable and
the factors which it relies on are the
independent variables
the remaining three variables are the
independent variables and in this case
they are average income
price and temperature
now we will perform linear regression to
see how they are affecting the
consumption rate
in order to perform linear regression in
r the first step you need to do is load
your data set in our workspace
we already had seen how to load the data
set into our workspace in previous
lessons
so we will now see how to perform linear
regression
using lm function define the dependent
and independent variables and store the
results in a new variable
here in our example it is given as lm of
consumption rate
tilde income price and temperature
let us save this in a variable called
analysis
now make a summary of this regression
analysis by calling the summary function
of the analysis variable
the results provide the call values that
is the formula which is being used for
regression analysis is being displayed
next comes the residuals term
it provides the minimum first quadrant
median third quadrant and maximum values
of the residual terms
the important interpretation is always
made from the term coefficients
this provides the intercept values and
estimate values of all independent
variables
from these results we also construct a
regression line and based on this line
we can draw a relationship between the
dependent and independent variables
we also predict the future values from
this equation and the accuracy of these
values always relies on the residual
term that is being generated
in the residual term values are less if
the residual term values are less the
accuracy of the predicted values will be
more
here from the obtained coefficients we
can draw the regression line as
consumption rate
equals
0.19 plus 0.0033
times income
minus 1.04
times price plus 0.0034
times temp plus
residuals from this regression line we
can predict the future consumption rate
by defining the income price and
temperature with its residual terms
the results also display the p value
from the low values of p for the income
and temperatures variables and the
significance codes we can see that these
two variables are more significant
from this and the positive coefficient
values we can conclude that if the
income level of the people is higher and
the temperature of that particular day
is more then there will be more sales of
ice cream
and the consumption rate of individuals
also will get increased
from the other row for price we can
deduce that if the value price is
negative then their consumption rate is
higher
that is if the price of the ice cream
goes down the demand for ice cream goes
higher and people tend to buy it more
the residual standard error that is
being calculated is about 0.036
and such a low value will not have much
impact on the predicted sales
the results also provide the multiple r
squared and adjusted r squared values
the r squared value obtained is about
0.71
that is 71 percent of relationship
between the dependent and independent
variable can be explained with the three
given factors
finally the f statistic value and the p
value are displayed
the p value that is being obtained is
less than 0.05 so we can reject the null
hypothesis and conclude that there is
some linear relationship between the
dependent and independent variables
we can summarize the results as follows
if price of ice cream gets lowered then
the consumption rate of individual would
increase
if the income of people and temperature
of particular locality is higher then
obviously your demand for ice cream will
increase and the consumption rate of ice
cream per individual will also go higher
these insights may help the company
authorities to make easy decisions on
their pricing and henceforth their
profitable range could be extended
in the next slide we will look at a case
where we use linear regression
an analytic startup is involved in
performing analytics for reverse
logistics
the people already employed by this
company have different working
experiences and they draw different
salaries
the company decided to monitor the
working skills of each employee and so
they introduce a format called
scoreboard rating
in this format each employee is rewarded
to score based on his or her working
performance
the employee is awarded a high score if
the working performance for that time
period has been good
the company wants to analyze and confirm
that if a higher experience and higher
score card rate leads to the employee
drawing a higher amount of salary
in order to analyze this we need to have
the data regarding salary experience and
score rating of individual employees
since it is a relatively new startup
they have only 20 employees and we have
the details of all the employees
the first variable specifies the years
of relevant work experience for the
employee
the second variable specifies the score
rating that the employee earned by his
performance
the third variable specifies the amount
that the employee is drawing as his
salary in thousands of dollars
in order to find the relationship
between these variables we need to
perform a linear regression model in our
tool
by this we can establish the
relationship between variables and we
can also predict the future values of
the dependent variable by constructing a
regression line
before performing regression analysis in
r we need to load the particular data
set into r for which we are going to
perform analysis
as loading of the data is discussed in
earlier lessons let us directly see how
to perform linear regression model in r
here in our example we need to check
whether salary of an employee is
dependent on scorecard rating and work
experience
so the dependent variable is salary and
the independent variables are score and
experience
we will perform the linear regression in
r using the lm function
the syntax as we know is lm of dependent
variable tilde independent variables
with the optional data attribute
in our case it is given as lm of salary
tilde experience plus score comma data
equals my data
assuming my data is the name of the data
frame where the data is stored
let us store the results in a variable
fit
then a detailed summary of this
regression should be obtained
to get the results in order to perform
this use the summary function with the
syntax summary of fit and press the
enter key to get the summary of the
regression analysis
the result shows the first line call and
this provides the formula which is being
specified to perform regression analysis
the next thing which is shown is the
residuals and this provides the
residuals value of minimum first
quadrant median third quadrant maximum
the next section specifies the important
results from which we can make useful
interpretations
that is the coefficients
this provides the estimate standard
error t statistic and p value
it also provides the intercept and
estimated value for both the experience
and score variables
from this result we can construct a
regression line as
salary equals
an intercept of 3.17
plus
1.40
times experience plus 0.25
times score plus the residuals
using this regression line we can
predict the future values of salary by
defining the value of experience and
score rating of each employee
the residual values obtained should be
lower
as otherwise it would affect the
predicted model
since both the coefficients are positive
we can also conclude from the given data
that if both experience and score rating
is high then the salary obtained by the
employee is also positive that is higher
the standard error value obtained is
also very low and so the deviation
between the predicted and actual value
is also low
this means that this model can predict
the accurate level values very easily
the t value obtained is higher and the p
value for both experience and score is
very low
and less than 0.05
this shows us that we need to reject the
null hypothesis and conclude that there
is some relationship between the
dependent and independent variables
the significance codes following the
p-values also suggest the same
next the standard residual error and the
degrees of freedom of those variables
are also being displayed
the results also contain the multiple r
squared and adjusted r squared value
the r squared value that is being
obtained is about 0.81
and this tells us that there is a
positive correlation between the
dependent and independent factors
in other words the difference in the
values of the salary can be explained
for 81 percent of the cases with the
given experience and rating factors
if independent variables move towards
the positive trend then obviously the
dependent variables also move towards
the positive trend
in terms of regression equation we can
make conclusions like the salary
increase is expected to be
one thousand four hundred four dollars
for each additional year of experience
when the aptitude score is at the same
level
the useful insight that we are drawing
from this analysis is that in this
analytics company if an employee is with
higher working experience and with
higher score ratings then we would
obviously draw a higher salary
and correspondingly if his experience
and score rate is lower then he would
get less salary thus confirming our
earlier assumptions
from this analysis we can also future
predict what salary should be provided
for a newly joined employee of this
company based on his or her individual
working experience and the score rating
in the next video we will look at how to
perform classification by now we know
several uses of linear regression and
why it is one of the widely used models
around
this case study will delve into how
linear regression can also be used to do
classification
surprised
let's see how
we will first install
ml bench package in r
we already know how to install a package
after installing the package it needs to
be loaded with the library command
we will be using a data set called
pima indians diabetes 2 from the package
the data consists of a population of 392
women with pima indian heritage
who live in the area of phoenix arizona
they were tested for diabetes
the goal is to get a classification rule
for the diagnosis of diabetes
the variables are
pregnant
number of times pregnant
glucose plasma glucose concentration
glucose tolerance test
pressure
diastolic blood pressure in millimeter
hg
triceps triceps skin fold thickness in
millimeter
insulin
two hours serum of insulin
milli units per milliliter
mass
body mass index
that is weight in kilograms divided by
height in meters squared
pedigree
diabetes pedigree function
age
age in years
diabetes
positive or negative
let us look at the head of the data set
here we need to predict or classify the
patient into right category of positive
or be negative
let us look at the complete data
we see that there are many missing
values which may be removed or inputted
for the sake of simplicity we will
remove the values
for that we use the n a
dot omit function
this will remove the rows which have n a
in any of the columns
this reduces our data set to
392 records
now for linear regression we need to
have numerical values
in our case
all the columns have numerical value but
diabetes column which has categorical
value
for this we will use the as dot numeric
function
also r gives a value of two for
pass
or one for
neg
so
we give the code in such a way that we
get zero for negatives and one for
positives
we store this data in a variable called
p-i-d-l-m
we look at the data through the head
function again and see we have converted
the diabetes value to zero or one
now the data set can be used to apply
linear regression
from this data set we then create a
train set
we take the first 300 records
the rest 92 records are put into the
variable called test
we could always use the random records
from the data set or use the other
things such as cross validation but
again for simplicity we are using the
first 300 records
next we call the lm function and set our
y as diabetes and dot represents all the
other columns on the data set train
let us have a look at the summary of the
fit
what do we observe
glucose is the most significant of all
the variables and the coefficient
estimate is positive
this is as expected
more glucose increases the chances to
testing positive
mass of the women also affects the
chance of being a diabetic
more the mass more the chances of being
a diabetic
pedigree also affects significantly and
positively
all other factors including age insulin
triceps pressure etc do not affect
diabetes significantly
the r square value for the fit is around
33 percent which for a practical case is
usually enough to go ahead
so now let us see how our fit performs
in predicting the values for the test
set
we use the predict function in r and put
it in a variable called predicted
if we see the predicted values we will
observe that the values coming are
between
are all less than one
now that we have the predicted
indicators values for whether a woman is
diabetic or not
we need to categorize these values into
positive or negative instances of
diabetes
we will define that if the values of
prediction are greater than 0.5
we will assume it to be a positive case
of diabetes
that is a value of one
else a negative case
a value of zero
we will then compare the predicted one
or zero with the actual values of
diabetes field from the test data set
for the comparison we create a table
called tab
which compares the predicted values and
the original diabetes value
let us understand the table
it tells us that there were a total of
62 cases
57 plus 5 of women with zero diabetes
value
57 of the predicted cases were false
with the logic of values greater than
0.5
giving a predicted value of 0 which
means they were successfully predicted
five cases the predicted values were
greater than 0.5
giving a predicted value of 1 even
though the original value was zero
similarly there were a total of thirty
cases nine plus twenty one of women with
one diabetes value
twenty one of the predicted cases were
true with the logic of values greater
than
0.5 giving a value of 1 which means they
were successfully predicted
nine cases the predicted values were
less than 0.5
giving a value of zero even though the
original value was one
so from here we can also calculate the
misclassification rate
total number of test cases is 92
number of successful predictions are 78
or number of missed classifications is
92 minus 78 equals 14.
misclassification rate is equal to 92
divided by 14 which give a value of
0.1521
you can also alternatively calculate the
miscalculation rate through a formula as
seen here
this again gives the value of
0.152179 choosing the threshold value of
0.5 as the dividing line for the
positive and negative was not exactly
scientific
so let us explore what happens if we
change the dividing line once with a
value higher than 0.5
that is 0.7
let us name the table as tab underscore
high
what do we see from the table
as expected it is giving a right
predictions of zero values
60 out of 62 cases whereas it is giving
more error with true cases
similarly let us keep the threshold
value to be low to be around 0.2
tab underscore low is the table name
if we see the table it is exactly the
opposite as the value 0.7
all the true cases 29 out of 30 are
being predicted perfectly whereas the
false cases are not
miscalculation rate for both 0.2 and 0.7
threshold value is higher than that of
0.5
so our initial guess was scientific
after all
also when you are solving a problem of
selecting the right classifier model you
can always use this miss rate and
compare it for different models
now that we have learned the basic of
linear regression in the next slide we
will look at logistic regression
it's a statistical method that is used
in analyzing data sets where one or more
independent variables would determine
the outcome of a dependent variable
in this type of regression the dependent
variables are binary
where the data is generally coded as one
for true and zero for false
that is dichotomous characteristics
the goal of logistic regression is to
find the best fitting model to describe
the relationship between the dichotomous
characteristic and a set of independent
variables
logistic regression generates the
coefficients of a formula to predict a
logit transformation of the probability
of presence of the characteristic of
interest
the formula is given by the equation
logit of p
equals beta naught plus beta 1 times x 1
plus beta 2 times x 2
plus beta 3 times x 3 etc up to beta n
times x n where p
is the probability of presence of the
characteristic of interest
the logit transformation
is defined as the load odds
where odds equals p divided by one minus
p
thus logic of p equals natural log of p
divided by one minus p
in the next slide we will look at the
method to develop a logistic model
in this slide we will see the steps to
build a logistic regression model
at first we finalize on data
that is the target and the predictor
variables
then we collect the data by defining
proper performance and observation
windows
before the data is used for further
analysis
data preparation and data treatment is
done
and hygiene check is done through
analysis
often we are required to create new
variables for the model
so we identify new or derived variables
from the given data
the next thing to be done is find
classing and course classing based on
some continuous variables if required
finally we get the logistic model and it
is analyzed through proper diagnostics
in the next slide we will look at the
differences between linear and logistic
regression
in this slide we will look at the key
differences between linear regression
and logistic regression
first let us recap what linear
regression is
linear regression is mainly used to
establish a relationship between
dependent and independent variables
it helps in estimating the impact of
independent variable over a dependent
variable
for example using a linear regression
model the relationship between
temperature t
and ice cream sales i
is found to be
i equals two t
plus four thousand
this equation says that for every one
degree rise in temperature there is a
demand of four thousand plus two
that is four thousand and two ice creams
on the other hand logistic regression
helps in finding out the probability of
an event
and this event is captured in binary
format that is zero or one
example in order to know whether
customers will buy a particular product
or not run a logistic regression on the
relevant data
here the dependent variable would be a
binary variable either one or zero that
is yes or no
in terms of graphical representation
linear regression gives a linear line as
an output
once the values are plotted on the graph
whereas the logistic regression gives an
s-shaped line corresponding to a
logistic function
in the next video we will look at the
commands to perform logistic regression
in r
in this video we will look at an example
case and see how logistic regression can
be implemented in r
an academic researcher is interested in
what variables affect a student's intake
to a graduate university and how each of
the factors affects the decision
he has collected the student's entrance
score
earlier grade point average
ranking of the undergraduate university
and the admission status
the admission status is either admit or
don't admit
and is a binary variable
the first step in working on the data is
to load the data set in r
we use the read dot csv command to read
the file into r and save it into
my data
let us first have a look at the data
using the head function
we can see that the admission status is
given as zero or one
zero denoting a failed admission and one
denoting a successful admission
then we have the entrance exam scores
and the undergraduate grade point
average
in the final column we have the ranking
of the undergraduate university
the rank takes on values one through
four with one denoting a highly
prestigious university and four being
the lowest in terms of prestige of the
university
the values of entrance exam scores and
grade point averages are continuous as
we can see here
we can get basic descriptive summary for
the entire data set by using the summary
function
we will change the rank and admission
status variables to factors
instead of numeric data now the summary
function shows the statistics for each
of the variables
we can see that out of the 400
applicants
127 of them got admission to the
university and the rest did not
most of the applicants belonged to
universities ranking second or third
for the exam scores and gpa variables
the mean
median minimum maximum and quartile
values are displayed
if you want to get the standard
deviations and other statistics use the
sapling function which was discussed in
earlier lessons
now we want to make sure that there are
no zero cells across the two categorical
variables
to check we create a contingency table
between the admission status and rank
variables using the x tabs function
so here we type
xtalbs
of tilde admit plus rank and specify the
data as my data
the table shows the admission status in
the rows and ranking across columns and
the number of occurrences in the
resulting matrix
here we see that there are no zero
columns and hence we proceed to the next
step
now we perform logistic regression on
the data
the glim or generalized linear model
function is used in r to create a
logistic regression model the glim
function takes attributes like the
formula
family
data weights
offset method etc
generally only the formula and data
attributes are used formula has the
general syntax
with the response variable and affecting
variables separated by tilde
now we will build a logistic regression
model using the glenn
function
now we type glen
of admit tilde gre plus gpa plus rank
specify the data attribute and mention
the family as binomial
and save the fit into a variable called
fit
to get the results we type summary of
now let us go through the results in
detail
similar to the lm output first we have
the function call which specifies the
model that was executed
and the different options specified
while executing the function
the next section displays the deviance
residuals which are useful in measuring
the model fit
this displays the minimum maximum medium
and quartile ranges of the residuals
obtained from the model
next the statistics coefficients are
displayed
the estimate standard errors the z
statistic also called a walled z
statistic
and the associated p values are
displayed
you can note that there are three rank
rows instead of a single rank row
since rank takes on any of four values
there are a total of n minus 1 or three
variables created
from the significance codes we can see
that both the gre and gpa variables are
statistically significant
as are the three terms for rank
the logistic regression coefficients
give the change in the logged odds of
the outcome for one unit increase in the
predictor variable
that is for every one unit change in gre
the log odds of admission versus not
admission increases by 0.002
for a one unit increase in gpa the log
odds of being admitted to graduate
school increases by 0.804
the indicator variables for rank have a
slightly different interpretation since
they are relative to the rank 1.
for example having attended an
undergraduate institution with rank of
three versus an institution with the
rank of one changes the log odds of
admission by
negative 1.340
finally we have the fit indices that
give the null deviances residual
deviances and the aic value
the aic value is used in comparing the
fit between two or more models
the calculation of aic values is
advanced and not a part of the
foundation course
in the next video we will look at how
logistic regression can be used in
predicting recurrent visits to a website
a leading boutique selling antique
jewelry made its entry into e-commerce
the management wants to analyze the
website data and accordingly make
business decisions to improve the
website
they hire an analytics firm to give
useful insights
one vital question that the analytics
firm wants to answer is whether the
users revisit the website within a day
or not
in this case study we will create a
logistic regression model to predict the
revisit patterns
the revisit of a particular user will
depend on both the user and the look and
feel of the website
however for this case since we wish to
analyze the user's pattern we will
primarily depend on the user's
characteristics
the google analytics data has been
generated for this website and we will
concentrate on data like the number of
visits the page where the users land or
exit etc the response variable in this
case is whether the user has made a
revisit within a day or not
this is denoted as zeros and ones with
ones denoting the presence of revisits
since there are only two predicted
outcomes the response variable is binary
and hence logistic regression can be
used in predicting the outcomes now we
will look at the different user
characteristics that we will use in
building the regression model
from the analytics data obtained we
choose seven characteristics of users to
work on
they are
visitor id
visit count
days since the last visit
medium
landing page path
exit page path
and the page depth
let us look at a brief description of
each of these values
the visitor id is a unique id for each
visitor
starting at one and incremented for each
new visitor
the visitor count is the number of
visits to the website made by the
particular user
for the first visit the visit count is
made as one
and is incremented for each consecutive
visit
the days since last visit column stores
the number of days between the previous
and current visit
medium has the source from which the
website has been visited and takes on
values like referral organic etc
the landing page and exit page paths
stores the pages on the website where
the user landed and from where the user
exited the website respectively
finally the page depth variable stores
the number of pages that the user
visited in a single visit to the website
here our goal is to predict whether a
user will return to the website in the
next 24 hours
from the collected data we can say that
a user would have to come back if his
visit count is more than one and the day
since the last visit is less than or
equal to one
based on this logic we will create a new
variable that stores the revisit status
with values of 0 and 1.
to build this model we will consider the
new variable that has been created as
the dependent variable
and the rest of the variables will be
considered as the independent variables
the next step is building the logistic
model
however before generating the model we
have an issue
in the last video we saw that for
categorical variables there are n
negative one dummy variables created in
logistic regression
for the rank variable in the previous
example there were four values of ranks
and three variables that were created to
build the model
in our case the medium landing path and
exit page path are categorical variables
from the summary we can see that medium
has 13 categories
the landing path has 78 categories and
the exit path has 158 categories
if we directly build the model a total
of 12 plus 77 plus 158
that is
247 dummy variables will be generated
the logistic model could still be built
however the interpretation of the model
will be unusually complex
to avoid this we can create the landing
page and exit page paths as numeric
values
by removing the page string
this might not be the best idea in most
cases but for the sake of simplicity
since this is a foundation course we
will use the simplest techniques
there are other solutions to this issue
but for this case we will focus on the
prediction model
now let us create the regression model
as seen earlier we will use the glim
function to create the model
let us name this model as revisit model
the glim contains formula as revisit
tilde days since last visit plus visit
count plus medium plus landing page path
plus exit page path plus page depth
the data attribute is mentioned as my
data
and the family is specified as binomial
after performing the regression we type
summary of revisit model to get the
linear regression summary
from the obtained results we can see
that there are 12 dummy variables
created for the medium variable
the deviance residuals are low and hence
our model is comparatively stable
from the significance codes in the
coefficients table we can note that the
days since last visit and medium
attributes are highly significant
the landing page path and exit page path
are of very less significance in
deciding whether the user revisits the
website or not
now let us find the efficiency of this
model
the fitted component of the logistic
model stores the predicted values of the
revisit on applying the model
we will type head of revisit model
dollar fitted to see the fitted values
you can see that the fitted value range
from zero to one
the values give us the probability that
the person will revisit within 24 hours
to convert it into a binary output we
will use the round function
the round function gives a value of 0 if
the input is less than 0.5 and 1
otherwise
we will store the results in a variable
and name it as predicted underscore
revisits
now we have the predicted revisit values
and the actual revisit values
to compare these two we will create a
comparison matrix using the f table
function
we will type f table of predicted
revisits comma my data dollar revisits
and store it in a variable called
comparison matrix
the final step is to find the accuracy
of the model
accuracy of the model is calculated as a
percentage of how successful the model
has been in predicting true against the
actual values
through the accuracy we can decide the
effectiveness of the model so we type
accuracy equals sum of diag
of comparison underscore matrix divided
by
2555 and multiply it by 100 to get the
percentage
here we get the percentage of 79.5
this shows that the model predicts the
correct values eighty percent of the
time
this concludes the basics for logistic
regression
in the next section we will look at
cluster analysis
let us now look at what cluster analysis
is all about
cluster analysis is the process of
forming groups of related variable for
the purpose of drawing important
conclusions based on the similarities
within the group
it is grouping the data objects based on
the information that is found in the
data that describes the objects in other
groups
the goal of this procedure is that the
objects in a group are similar to one
another and are different from the
objects in other groups
the greater the similarity within a
group and greater the difference between
the groups more distinct is the
clustering
cluster analysis provides a way for
users to discover potential
relationships and construct systematic
structures in large numbers of variables
and observations
the figure on the slide shows the main
objective of clusters
the intra distance between observations
in a single cluster should be minimized
and the inter-cluster distance between
two observations belonging to different
clusters should be maximized
in the next slide we will look at the
different types of clusters
in this slide we will list out the most
common types of clusters and explain
each of them briefly
first we have hierarchical clusters
they are also known as nesting clusters
as it also clusters to exist within
bigger clusters to form a tree
partition clustering is simply a
division of the set of data objects into
non-overlapping clusters such that each
object is exactly one subset
exclusive clustering is a type of
clustering where they assign each object
to a single cluster
overlapping clustering is used to
reflect the fact that an object can
simultaneously belong to more than one
group
in fuzzy clustering
every object belongs to every cluster
with a membership weight that goes
between zero if it absolutely doesn't
belong to that cluster and one if it
absolutely belongs to the cluster
finally complete clustering performs a
hierarchical cluster analysis using a
set of dissimilarities on the objects
that are being clustered
they tend to find compact clusters of
approximately equal diameters
in the next slide we will look at the
types of clusters
clustering is mainly to determine the
useful groups of clusters where its
usefulness is defined by the goals of
data analysis
here in this slide we will look at some
of the different types of clusters
the first one here is well separated
clusters
a cluster is a set of objects in which
each object is closer to every other
object in the cluster than to any object
which is not in the cluster
this definition comes into picture only
when data contains natural clusters that
are pretty far from each other
the distance between any two points in
different groups is greater than the
distance between any two points within a
group
they need not be globular
now coming to the next one
prototype base cluster
in this type of cluster the cluster is
closer to the prototype that defines the
cluster then the prototype of any other
cluster
the prototype of a cluster is often a
centroid for data with continuous
attributes
such clusters tend to be globular
next type of cluster is graph based
where the data is represented as a graph
where nodes are the objects and links
represent connection among the objects
they tend to be globular
there is another type of cluster called
density based clusters
in this type a cluster is a dense region
that is surrounded by a region of low
density
this method is employed when the
clusters are irregular and when noise
and outliers are present
the last one to be discussed in this
slide is the shared property cluster
in general we can define this cluster to
be a set of objects that share some
common properties between themselves
also known as conceptual clustering
it is the process of identifying the
pattern in the clusters to successfully
segregate into groups of clusters
in the next slide we will look at the
methods to form
clusters in this slide we will discuss
about the three important techniques to
bring in the concepts of cluster
analysis
the first and most common method is the
k-means
clustering k-means cluster analysis is
used to classify observations through k
number of clusters
the idea is to minimize the distance
between the data and the corresponding
cluster centroid
k-means analysis is based on one of the
simplest algorithms for solving the
cluster problem and is therefore much
faster than hierarchical cluster
analysis
the k-means analysis is typically
considered when the sample size is
larger than 100.
note however that k-means cluster
analysis assumes that the centroid of
the observations or
at least the number of groups to be
clustered is already known
the next method is agglomerative
hierarchical clustering
as seen in the previous slides this
approach refers to a collection of
closely related clustering techniques
that produce a hierarchical clustering
by starting with each point as a
singleton cluster and then repeatedly
merging the two closest clusters until a
single all-encompassing cluster remains
some of these techniques have a natural
interpretation in terms of graph based
clustering while the others have an
interpretation in terms of a prototype
based approach
finally we have db scan
this is a density based clustering
algorithm that produces partial
clustering in which the number of
clusters is automatically determined by
the algorithm
points in low density regions are
classified as noise and emitted
and thus db scan and thus db scan
doesn't produce a complete clustering
in the next slide we will look at the
command to perform clustering in r
in this example we are going to see how
to perform k-means clustering on a data
set in r
k-means is one of the most commonly used
algorithms in cluster analysis
the goal of this algorithm is to find
the best division of the anon titles or
observations into k groups
in k means clustering the total distance
between the group members and its
corresponding centroid for each
representation of the group is being
minimized
the main aim of partition is to minimize
the within cluster sum of squares value
in this example here we have four
objects
and each object has two distinct
features
our goal is to group these objects into
groups based on their two features
hence for this case k equals two
to perform this k-means cluster we will
first load the data set into our
workspace and save it in a variable
called cluster example
we have three attributes
object attribute x and attribute y
after loading the data set we will
define the object variable as null
to perform the clustering on only the
attributes
the k-means function is used in
performing this clustering in r the
syntax is k-means of data set comma the
centroid values
here we will type the data set name as
cluster example and give the number of
centroids as two
and store the output in a variable named
results
on clicking enter the k means clustering
results are displayed
the results provide the mean value of
the clusters of attribute x and
attribute y
next it displays the clustering vector
that is which object was assigned to
which cluster
as we have k equals two all the data
points fall within the two categories
either one or two
the within cluster sum of squares by
cluster value is 0.5 for the first
cluster and 1.0 for the second cluster
the ratio of between sum of squares and
total sum of squares is given as 91
percentages
the result also shows the available
components for the clustering results
the cluster component shows the
clustering vector
with centers giving a matrix of the
cluster center values
the toss ss
within ss between ss etc store the total
sum of squares within sum of squares
between sum of squares values
the size component has the number of
points that have been assigned to each
cluster
any of these components can be displayed
by typing results
component name
now let us view a graphical
representation of these clusters
to do so
we will make a plot
within the two variables
attribute x and attribute y of the
cluster example data set comma
col equals result dollar cluster to
specify the clusters in different colors
the plot shows the two points of each
cluster in different colors
now we will try to plot the centers of
these clusters to view the cluster
centroids
the points function is used here to plot
the points on an already existing graph
we will use the centers component of the
clustering result to plot the centroids
so we now type points of results dollar
centers comma
col
equals one to two
comma
pch equals eight
cex
equals two and click enter
the col specifies r to use different
colors for the points
and the pc h specifies which character
to use to depict the color
in this case we are displaying a star
cex attribute expands or displays the
character in a larger size
now we can see the two cluster centroids
for the clusters displayed in a star
with colors corresponding to each
cluster
we can note that the cluster centroids
are placed approximately at the center
of the two points
this video is to show a simple
explanation of how the clustering is
done
and how they can be viewed graphically
in the next video we will look at a
second way of clustering algorithm that
is hierarchical clustering in this
example let us look at the case of an
economic survey to explain hierarchical
clustering
the european union advisory board wants
to take an economic sustainability
survey for all the countries in their
committee board
the survey includes details on the
following information such as
name of country
the area in square feet
the gdp or the gross domestic product
value
the inflation rate that the country
faces
the average life expectancy of people
living in the country
the military group rate
the population growth of that particular
country
and the rate of unemployment in the
now they plan to group the countries
based on their similarities so that
their decision making can be made easier
in order to find similarity in
observations and group the data we need
to perform cluster analysis
in this example we will use hierarchical
clustering to group the countries
this cluster analysis also allows us to
summarize the data by grouping all the
similar observations into different
clusters
these observations are made by
considering similar values for number of
variables
that is if the euclidean distance
between two values is less than they are
grouped together we can perform cluster
analysis with the dist and h-clust
function
the dist function calculates a distance
matrix of the provided values and
provides the euclidean distance between
those values by default
from the calculated euclidean distance
hierarchical clustering can be derived
to perform this we use the h-clust
function
the h-clust function has a method
attribute that specifies how the
clustering is to be done
the methods include average ward
single
median complete and centroid methods
with the complete linkage method being
the default
first we will load the data set into the
current r workspace and save it in a
variable named europe
the syntax to perform hierarchical
clustering is h clust of dist of data
set name
so here we type h clust of dest of
europe and store the results in a
variable named
euroclust
the -1 next to europe is to remove the
first column
that is country name
while performing the clustering since it
does not have a logical relationship
with the data
now let us view the results of
clustering in the form of a dendogram
as we already know the dendogram
displays the order of merging for the
given data set
the plot function can be used with the
clustering results variable to plot the
dendagram
the syntax to draw the dendrogram is
plot of model name
by default the row numbers or row names
are used to label the observations
here to make it clearer we will use the
country names to label the observations
by using the labels attribute
so now we type plot of euroclust comma
labels equal to europe dollar country
on expanding the plot we can see the
countries that are grouped first based
on their similarities
for example spain and sweden finland and
germany austria and ireland netherlands
and switzerland have closest
similarities
from the right corner of the graph we
can make out that slovenia belgium
denmark netherlands and switzerland are
tightly knit or quite similar to one
another in terms of economic
sustainability
same could be said for estonia slovakia
croatia latvia and lithuania
however this interpretation is
completely based on visual content
we can also make clusters from these
dendrograms in r by using the rect dot h
clust method
the method takes the model name and the
number of clusters as argument
for our example let us try to make the
five clusters
so we type r-e-c-t
dot h-clust of euro clust comma five
the dendogram now shows five rectangles
in red
ukraine forms a single cluster and thus
we can see that it is completely
different from the other countries in
terms of economic status
next spain and sweden form a cluster the
final cluster has 11 countries so that
we can see that these eleven countries
are quite similar to each other
now let us try with four clusters
we will type r e c t
dot
h clust of euroclust comma four
the dendogram shows that the earlier
clusters four and five have been merged
into a single cluster
so in conclusion the european union can
decide to make similar decisions to have
a single advising committee for the 19
countries and ukraine has to be given
special attention
in the next slide we will look at a case
study and implement both k-means and
hierarchical clustering and compare
their results
for our case study we will take the case
of the iris data set in r
the iris data set contains five
variables namely sepal length
sepal width
petal length petal width and species
of three kinds of iris flowers
in this video we will try to cluster the
three species of flowers with their
sepal and petal attributes using the
clustering functions in r and compare
the results
in this example we will use the k-means
and hierarchical clustering methods
first we will perform k-mean clustering
using r
to recap k-means is a clustering
methodology in which we will choose k
number of initial centroids
where the value of k is specified by the
user
in k means the number of clusters or
centroids is a user specified parameter
each point is then assigned to the
closest centroid and the collection of
points assigned to a centroid forms a
cluster
the centroid of each cluster is then
updated iteratively depending on the
points assigned to the cluster
this process is repeated till the
centroid does not change between the two
iterations
now let us perform k-means clustering on
the given data set in r
to do so first we load the iris data set
into the r workspace
here we are loading the iris data set
into a variable named new iris
next we are going to perform clustering
based on siebel length
simple width
petal length and petal width
note that we are excluding the species
variable as it is a categorical variable
and is the desired output for clusters
so in order to exclude this species
variable we mark the variable as null
the syntax for defining this is
new iris
dollar species equals null
now for the k means clustering we need
to specify the number of initial
centroids
in our example we are going to form
three clusters
so we will define the value of initial
centroid values as three
in this case since we know that there
are three types of species we specify
the number as three
for cases where we do not know the
number of clusters choosing the right
number of clusters itself needs some
careful consideration
the simplest way to choose the right
number of clusters is by trial and error
now finally we are going to perform
k-means clustering
and we will store the resultant values
in a new variable named kc
to do so we type kc equals k-means of
new iris comma 3
where new iris is the name of the data
frame and three is the number of initial
centroids
to view the results we type kc in the
console and press enter
from the displayed results we can see
that three clusters have been formed
with sizes of sixty two fifty and thirty
eight
in the next section the mean value of
all attributes for these clusters are
displayed
we can see the mean value of siebel
length simple width pedal length and
pedal width for all three clusters that
have been formed
for example from the pedal width column
we can see that flowers with a very low
width of almost zero belong to the
second cluster
slightly wider flowers with the width of
around 1.5 belong to the first cluster
and the widest flowers with a petal
width of 2 belong to the third cluster
this is a mean value and thus there
might be exceptions
however it gives us an overall outlook
of how the flowers are different
then it provides the clustering vector
values to all of the rows present in the
data set
this cluster vector value shows the
cluster category to which each row of
data belongs to
in this example we have three clusters
and so the values range from one to
three
the next result which is being shown is
the within cluster sum of squares by
clusters
this shows the value of sum of squares
of each individual clusters
the result also provides the available
components of clusters that are the
object of class k means
we will look at each of the components
here the first component cluster
provides the vector of integers from 1
to k
indicating the cluster to which each
point is allocated
this is same as our earlier output
showing the cluster that each point has
been allocated to
the centers component provides the
matrix of cluster center that is the
clustering vector that is displayed
the within ss component provides the
within cluster sum of squares of each
cluster
the size component provides the number
of points in each cluster
that is 62 50 and 38
now let us compare the species label
with the clustering results obtained
to compare we will first make a table
with the species and the corresponding
cluster values for each row
now we will plot the observation points
and then plot their clusters and centers
there are basically four dimensions in
our data
corresponding to four variables
however for the sake of simplicity we
are going to consider only two
dimensions
that is simple length and sepal width
for this plot we type plot of new iris
of c of sepal length comma sepal width
comma
col equals kc
dollar cluster
we will plot the centers of clusters in
different colors so we use the points
option with the clustered center value
of both sepal length and sepal width the
col option controls the color of symbol
border and by default the color is black
the pch value is used to specify
different symbols other than points in a
plot if the pch value is between 21 and
25 then the parameters col and bg should
be specified
the cex value controls the symbol size
in plot
the plot that we finally obtained shows
three different clusters with their
center values and these are grouped
based on their nearest centroid values
now we will use hierarchical clustering
for our example to group the related
variables
as we have already seen in hierarchical
clustering the data is not partitioned
into a particular cluster in a single
step
instead a series of partitions take
place which run from a single cluster
containing all objects to n clusters
each containing a single object
hierarchical clustering may be
graphically represented by a
two-dimensional diagram known as a
dendogram
which illustrates the fusions or
divisions made at each successive stage
of analysis
hierarchical clustering can be
implemented using a variety of methods
based on how two clusters are being
combined
here in our clustering model we are
going to use average linkage clustering
methodology
in this methodology the distance between
two clusters is defined as the average
of distances between all pairs of
objects
where each pair is made up of one object
from each group
here the sum of pairwise distance
between two clusters is being calculated
at each stage of clustering with
clusters with minimum values of distance
are merged together
we use the h clust method to perform
hierarchical clustering on the iris data
so here we type
h clust
of dist of iris and method equals
average and save it in a variable
hc here the dist method calculates the
euclidean distance between two points
and method species that we are using the
average linkage method to perform the
clustering
to view dendograms in a clearer format
we will just use a sample of 40 records
from iris data
we will take a random sample of the data
set by using the sample function and
store the indices in a variable idx
so type idx equals sample of 1 to
dimension of iris of 1 comma 40.
the data set is now created as iris
sample equals iris of idx null
we will again perform clustering on this
sample data set
note that the species value should be
set to null
otherwise the clustering will yield
exact results using the species column
now let us visualize the dendrogram by
using the plot option with hang and
labels values
the hang values specify the plot height
by which labels should hang below the
rest of the plot
if the hang values are being specified
as negative then it will cause the
labels to hang down from zero
in our case the hang value which we
specified is negative one
the species label should be displayed in
the dendogram so that the labels defined
as iris dollar species
now this dendogram that is obtained
shows the grouping of the individual
observations in every step till a single
cluster is reached
we can see from this case study that for
this case the k means algorithm performs
well
this is since we know the number of
clusters and the cluster centroids can
thus be easily
obtained when the number of clusters is
unknown the hierarchical algorithms may
be used to get an overall idea of how
the observations are spaced or related
to each other
this concludes the section on clustering
in the next slide we will look at time
series data
time series data is an ordered sequence
of observations on a quantitative
variable measured over an equally space
time interval
time series are used in statistics
signal processing pattern recognition
econometrics mathematics finance weather
forecasting earthquake prediction
electro and cephalography control
engineering astronomy communications
engineering and many other places
time series analysis is a set of methods
used in analyzing time series data and
forecasting the future value of the
variable under consideration
in time series analysis it is assumed
that the data consists of set of
identifiable components and random
errors which usually make the pattern
difficult to identify
consider a store that sells blankets and
quilts then the sales data of quilts and
blankets across a period of five years
is an example of time series data
in the next slide we will look at the
components of a time series
trend and seasonality are the main
in this slide we will look at each of
the components in detail
first we will discuss long-term trend
it is the smooth long-term direction of
time series where the data can increase
or decrease in some pattern
next is seasonal variations
seasonality is patterns of change in a
time series within a year which tends to
repeat every year
cyclical variation is much alike
seasonal variation but the rise and fall
of time series over periods are longer
than one year
irregular variation is any variation
that is not explainable by any of the
three above mentioned components
however that doesn't necessarily mean
that the variations are random
they can be classified into stationary
and non-stationary variation
when the data neither increases nor
decreases that is it is completely
random it is called stationary variation
when the data has some explainable
portion remaining and can be analyzed
further than such cases called
non-stationary variation
in the next slide we will look at a
comparison of cyclical and seasonal time
series
in the previous slide we just saw the
definition of cyclical and seasonal time
series analysis
now let's see how they are different
an important characteristic of a time
series is that the data experiences some
kind of predictable and regular changes
over a period of time
when the changes occur over a period of
time less than or more than a year then
they are cyclical variations
for example boost in sales due to
inflation or change in the fashion trend
every five years
seasonal changes are changes that occur
over a period of one year
for example increased sale of blankets
and quilts in winter or sunscreen in
summer are seasonal trends
it can also be related to increased sale
and gifts during christmas and new year
these effects occur every year and it is
logical that if the surge in sales
occurs for one year it will in most
probabilities occur for the next year as
well
seasonal changes are important to be
remembered since it will help in
strategy and planning for example
predicting the spurt in sales and
filling up the inventories or making
decisions on staffing will help in
boosting the sales
however the cyclical effects are more
difficult to predict since they are
rarely observed in normal time series
data
and thus are more complex to remove
in the next slide we will look at
decomposition of time series data
decomposing a time series refers to
separating it into its constituent
components
which as we have seen earlier usually
comprises of a trend component and an
irregular component and if it's a
seasonal time series than a seasonal
component
it's assumed that actual time series
value at period t
is a function of three components
trend component
seasonal component
and an irregular or error component
the decomposition of time series can
either be additive or multiplicative
as the name suggests an additive
decomposition model adds the three
components and takes the following form
y of t equals trend plus seasonal plus
irregular components
correspondingly in the multiplicative
model the components are multiplied and
hence take the form
y of t equals trend multiplied by
seasonal multiplied by irregular
components
for any time series the three components
can be extracted or separated from the
original time series
a time series that has seasonal effects
removed is called
deseasonalized time series
in the next slide we will talk about the
process of decomposing seasonal and
trend data
in the previous slides we talked about
the trend and seasonal components of
time series
if the time series can be described
using an additive model
r has an inbuilt function called
decompose to estimate the trend seasonal
and irregular components of a time
series
the decompose function can also be used
on multiplicative models by specifying
the type as multiplicative
the result of the decompose function is
a list object that contains the
estimates of the seasonal component
trend component and irregular component
which are stored in named elements of
that list objects called seasonal trend
and random respectively
the function first estimates the trend
component from the time series by using
the moving average technique and then
removes the component
next the seasonal component is
calculated by averaging for each
observation over the complete period of
time
then the seasonal component is removed
and centered
finally for an additive model the trend
and seasonal component is subtracted
from the original time series to obtain
the residuals or error terms
the decompose function works well when
the time series data covers a complete
period of time for example 36 or 48
months instead of 30 or 40 months
this function is used in computing the
components of a seasonal time series
in the next video we will look at an
example of how to work with time series
data
we will now get started with a case
study in time series analysis for better
understanding of what we just learned in
the slides
for this example we are going to use two
files that can be accessed from the
rutgers university data
one file has details on the unemployment
rates and the other file contains data
on the inflation rates from standard
government sources
first let's read the file into r
to access the data from the url we will
store the url values into two variables
web 1
with the unemployment rates and web 2
with the inflation rates
now let's read this file into r using
the r dot csv function
so we type dot csv of web one comma
row
dot names equals one
and assign a name to this data set say
unemploy
now let's see if the data is correctly
loaded in r
so type head of
unemployed
we see the first six rows of data and
they are across two columns
the first column shows the dates from
1948 and the second column displays the
unemployment rate
now we will do the same with inflation
also
we will read the data from url and save
it to a variable called inflate
so inflate equals to read.csv
of web2 comma row.names
equals
1.
now to check if the data has been loaded
we type head of inflate
and similar to the unemployment we can
see two columns
one showing the date and the other
showing the inflation data
now we shall check the class of
unemployed
and it shows it as data frame
so we need to convert them into time
series object to see a time component
so we use the ts function by typing ts
of unemploy dollar value comma start
equals c of 1948 comma one comma freck
equals 12.
let's assign a name to this say
your rate
here we are performing time series on
the object value in the unemployment
data set and extracting the numerical
column using the dollar sign
then we are telling r that this is
monthly data starting from 1948 the
first month onwards and goes on for 12
months
now we will check the data
type head of your rate
and we can look at the data we just put
in
and the data is now segregated based on
the months
so now when we check the class of your
rate it shows as ts
similarly we can check the class of
inflation and it shows a data frame
we will do the same as we did to
unemployment data so irate equals ts of
inflate
dollar value
comma start equals c of 1948 comma one
comma freck equals 12
class of irate is now ts
now let's look at the time function
time of your rate
if we check the time of the data it
looks a little unusual we can see 1948
1948.083
1948.167 etc with the decimals
so it's a decimal representation of the
data
we can see 1948.000
for january month of the year as it's
the first month
then followed by february and it shows
point zero eight three which is the one
twelfth of the way through the year
point 167 is the one-sixth of the way
through the year for march and then
april shows one-fourth of the way
through the year and goes on showing one
half to be in july etc
this is to subtract two time periods at
a time when required
now we will look at another command that
is window
it will just slice out a part of the
time from the data
this allows us to select a particular
month
for this case let's do it for the august
so your rate dot august equals window of
your rate comma
start equals c of 1980 comma eight comma
freck equals true
frequency equals true means we are
asking r to choose only the eighth month
now we will see the data we have
extracted by typing your rate dot august
so we can see the data for every august
month starting from 1980 till 2011
we will plot the time series object or
rate and we see that there is a time
dimension seeing the swings
now we will plot your rate dot august
this also has time dimensions but with
wider swings
now let's plot a regression line to see
the trend of the time series
we will first plot the rate time series
and then use the ab line function
so type ab line of reg equals lm of your
rate tilde time of your rate
from the ab line we can see that there
is a slight upward trend in the time
series data
now we will come to an important
function called the decompose function
the decompose function in r will show
which are the seasonal components which
are the random components and which are
the trend components in just one command
so type decompose of your rate
the results show the seasonal trend and
random components
so now we have all the raw data
it will be easier to understand if we
plot the data
so we type plot of decompose of your
rate
we now get a nice plot to analyze
here is the raw data in the first row
the trend in the second row
and so it has kind of smoothened that
trend a little bit
then we can see the seasonal component
going up and down and then there is the
random component that is the part which
remains unexplained by the trend
seasonal and cyclical variations
now let us compare the two rates against
each other
that is the inflation rate versus the
unemployment rate
let us give plot of year rate comma
irate
the result is just a standard scatter
plot and it doesn't have anything unique
about it as it is just normal data
points
also it is hard to see if there is any
pattern however it looks like it is
unlikely for unemployment and inflation
to be high at the same time since the
top right corner of the plot is empty
but if we wish to compare the pattern of
inflation rate with the unemployment
then we can use a time series plot
to view the time series plot we type ts
dot plot of irate comma you rate comma
col equals to c of blue comma red to
display the variables in different
colors
this ts plot recognizes the time
dimension and thus gives a neat display
of the time series data
since both the data belong to the same
time period it is a neat way of
comparing two time series data
in the next slide we will talk about
decomposing non-seasonal time series
a non-seasonal time series does not
contain any seasonal changes in the time
series data
to estimate the trend component of a
non-seasonal time series we can use any
common smoothing methods such as moving
average or exponential smoothing
the ttr package in r has functions for
decomposing non-seasonal time series
it can be installed in r using the
install dot packages function
the most commonly used smoothing
techniques are displayed below with a
very brief description
simple moving average
in this type the time series is
smoothened using a simple moving average
of a given number of observations or
time intervals
for example if the interval is five
weeks the average of previous five weeks
data is taken as the forecast for the
sixth week
for the seventh week the data of weeks
two through six are averaged and so on
this is by far the simplest technique in
time series smoothing
exponential moving average
in this technique the averaging is done
exponentially
the immediately previous data is given
more preference than the past data and
the weight for the past data decreases
exponentially
the damping factor alpha is used in
smoothing or damping the time series
weighted moving average
the weighted moving average is very
similar to the simple moving average
technique
except that weights are assigned to the
previous data
that is different weights are assigned
to different positions of the moving
average window generally the weights
decrease in arithmetic progression
the simple moving average function takes
an argument of n which specifies the
order of span of the moving average
window
for the previous example that we
discussed to average values over a
period of 5 weeks or months the order
has to be set as 5 in the sma function
in the next slide we will talk about
exponential smoothing in detail
exponential smoothing is a very popular
scheme to produce a smoothened time
series
as mentioned earlier
here the recent observations are given
relatively more weight in forecasting
than the older observations
this method is useful for making
forecasts and makes no assumptions about
the correlations between successive
value of the time series
to make prediction intervals for
forecasts using exponential smoothing
methods the forecast errors must be
uncorrelated and normally distributed
with mean zero and constant variance
exponential smoothing can also be viewed
as an extension and generalization of
moving average smoothing technique
since it is additive with exponentially
decreasing weights
one major advantage of the exponential
smoothing method is that it continually
revises a forecast in the light of more
recent experience
that is it keeps adding the recent
observations and gives the forecast
accordingly
and hence is more indicative of the
current trend
also it smoothens out the difference
between the last actual data and its
forecasted value
in the next slide we will talk about
simple exponential forecasting
the simplest of the exponentially
smoothing methods is naturally called
simple exponential smoothing or ses for
short
it is also called single exponential
smoothing
this method is suitable for forecasting
data with no trend or seasonal pattern
if there is a time series that can be
described using an additive model with
constant level and no seasonality
exponential smoothing can be used to
make short-term forecasts
it provides a way of estimating the
level at the current time point
smoothing is controlled by the parameter
alpha for the estimate of the level at
the current time point
the value of alpha or the damping factor
lies between zero and one
values of alpha that are close to zero
mean that little weight is placed on the
most recent observations when making
forecasts of future values
the forecasted value f t for y of t is
given by
f of t plus one
equals alpha times of y
t
plus one minus alpha times f t
in the next slide we will look at a
little more complex method the holt's
exponential smoothing
the exponential smoothing we just
discussed in the previous slide is known
as the simple smoothing method
and it doesn't consider the existence of
trend or seasonal component
hence we extend the concept of
exponential smoothing
and now we will see holt's exponential
smoothing
it's a method where we consider the
existence of trend values in the data
it fits the trend values
non-parametrically rather than the way
we learned in the previous slides
in holt's exponential smoothing we do
the smoothing in two ways
firstly like an exponential smoothing we
smooth between last actual data and its
forecasted data
secondly we find out the trend component
by smoothing difference between the last
two forecasted values and the last trend
value calculated
mathematically holt's estimate
h t is given by f t
plus one
equals alpha times of y t
plus or minus alpha times of f t plus t
t
then t t plus one equals gamma times f t
plus one minus f t plus one minus gamma
times t t
then we have the whole estimate h t
given by h t plus one equals f t plus
one
plus
t t plus one
there are two parameters to be estimated
which are alpha and gamma
we also need to know the initial value f
not t not
we assume f not equals to y
not and not t
not equals y one minus y naught
as there are two steps in this smoothing
this method is also called double
exponential smoothing or two parameter
exponential smoothing
in the next slide we will look at the
holt winter's exponential smoothing
in this method we will take care of the
seasonality effect in the holt's
smoothing method
winter's method is also known as holt
winter's method of forecasting
it assumes multiplicitive seasonal
effect and additive trend components
the smoothening method consists of four
equations and three parameters
ft equals alpha times
yt divided by st
minus p
plus one minus alpha times
f t
minus one
plus t t
it involved finding and removing the
deseasonalized component ft after
removing the seasonal effect
then the second step
st equals to beta times yt
divided by ft plus one minus beta times
s t minus p
here it's revising the seasonal effect
considering the ratio between actual
value at t
and its deseasonalized value now let us
look at the third step
t t equals gamma times
f t
minus f t minus 1
plus 1 minus gamma times t t
minus one
in the final equation we revise the
trend component as it is done in holt's
method
now finally
wt plus m equals to f t
plus one plus m
times t t
plus one times s t
plus m minus p
so it is combining the d seasonalized
value trend component and seasonal
component to make a m period ahead
forecast
in these equations st is seasonalized
component at time t p is the length of
the season
beta is the seasonal smoothing parameter
that lies between zero to one
and m is the ahead forecast we wanted to
make that is less than or equal to p
in the next slide we will look at the
advantages and disadvantages of
exponential smoothing
firstly we will list the advantages of
exponential smoothing is
easy to understand
easy to implement
and its continual learning process
the disadvantages of using exponential
smoothing are listed now
firstly the prediction can be made only
to recent future
it doesn't look at actual relationship
with past
its accuracy falls for less number of
data
in the next slide we will look at
exponential smoothing and forecasting
techniques in r
the most commonly used models are
ets
arima
holt winters
erima and holt winters work on seasonal
data by default but arima needs more
data at least four seasons than the
latter
arima and holt's winter are used in
longer forecasting quarter year to five
years whereas holt's method and simple
exponential smoothing are used in
shorter periods
we will now look at the ways to perform
a holtz winters by using different
smoothing functions
halt winters by ets is given by
ets
of z
a
and m
z implies that the model will be
automatically selected
that is
additive or multiplicative
holt winters by erima is given by
arima of zero
comma two comma two
to add seasonality part add option
seasonality equals list of order equals
c of
zero comma two comma two
to compare the different methods ets and
arima work only on univariate time
series
for multivariate series we will use holt
winters or the mts package in r
in the next video we will look at an
example of holt winters in
r
now we will see an example of holt
winter's exponential smoothing
a halt winter is used to make short-term
forecasts on the data set
this method is used in estimating the
level slope and seasonal component
the smoothing of data is controlled
using the three parameters of alpha beta
and gamma
the parameter alpha is used for the
estimates of the level
the parameter beta is used for the
estimates of slope of the trend
component
and the parameter of gamma does the
estimation of seasonal component at the
current time point
all the three parameters alpha beta and
gamma are having values between zero and
one
the values that are close to zero
indicate that relatively little weight
is placed on the most recent
observations when making forecasts of
future values
holt's winters can best be explained by
using the example of any sales data dot
i n
this example we shall look into example
of the cola shop at a beach resort at a
town in mania island
this data is an example of time series
that can be probably described using an
additive model with a trend and
seasonality
to make the forecasting of this data we
can fit a predictive model using holt's
winter's function
to begin with let's first look up the
data from this url given here
so type cola1 equals to scan of the url
now to check if the correct data set is
imported we shall type cola1 and press
enter
so now we can see the raw data that was
available on the mentioned url
we can see there are totally 84 data in
the list
now we shall check the class of this
data set
so type class of cola 1
so we can see the class result shows
that it's a numeric data
so now we will convert this data set
from numeric to ts or time series
so type cola 2 equals to ts of cola 1
comma
freck
equals to 12 comma start equals to c of
1987 comma 1.
to check if the data is converted to
time series check its class again
so type class of cola 2 and we can see
that it shows
ts
now to see how the data looks in time
series
type cola 2 and press enter
into the 12 months
so now we can see the sales of cola at
the shop for every month
we shall now make a plot of the time
series data
so type plot dot ts of cola 2.
and we can see the trend of the data and
how there's a peak in sales towards the
end of the year
and also there is a rise in sales size
of seasonal fluctuations and random
fluctuations are increasing with the
level of time series
so the solution to this is that we will
have to transform the time series in
order to get a time series that can be
used for the additive model
in this case let's transform it with the
natural logarithm of the original data
that we are having
so type log cola to log equals to log of
cola 2
and then plot dot ts
of log cola 2.
so now in this plot we can see that the
size of fluctuations and randomness in
this log transform plot shows to be
roughly constant over time and this
doesn't depend in any way on the level
of the time series
therefore we can now use this log
transform time series for additive model
now we will fit the predictive model for
the monthly sales of cola with the log
transformed time series data
so
cola to forecast equals to holt winters
of log cola 2.
now to check the result type cola to
forecast and press enter
we can see the result showing holt
winter's exponential smoothing with
trend and additive seasonal component
the smoothing parameters here as we can
see in the result is alpha equals to
0.4134
beta equals to 0 and gamma equals to
0.95
the value of alpha that we can see from
the result as 0.4134
is relatively low
this indicates that the estimated level
at current time point is based on recent
observations and some observations of
very distant past
the value of beta here is zero and this
indicates that the slope b of the trend
component has not been updated over the
time series
this is instead been set equal to zero
to its initial value
this result makes a good intuitive
result so as the level changes over the
time series the slope b of the trend
component will happen to remain more or
less same
contrasting to this situation we have
the gamma value that shows a very high
number that is 0.956
this indicates that the estimate we have
of the seasonal component at the current
point of time is actually based on a
very recent observation
now
let's see what will happen if we
manipulate the beta and gamma values
so type hw1
equals to holt winters of log cola two
comma beta equals to one comma gamma
equals to one
then type hw1 and press enter
now we can see the result of whole
winters for beta and gamma values equal
to 1.
so the alpha value we see is 0.4119
this means that the data is from the
recent past
the beta value showing 1 means that the
slope b of the trend component has been
updated over the time series
and then the gamma value is equals to
one
this is a contrasting situation with a
very high value of one
this means that the estimate we are
having of the seasonal component of the
time series is actually based upon a
very recent observation
next we will try holt winters for beta
value to be 1 and gamma value to be 0.
so type hw2
equals to holt winters of log cola two
comma beta equals to one comma gamma
equals to zero
we can see the result showing holt
winters exponential smoothing with trend
and additive seasonal component
the smoothing parameters here as we can
see in the result is alpha equals to
0.4016
beta equals to 1 and gamma equals to 0.
the value of alpha that we can see from
the result as 0.40126
is relatively low
this indicates that the estimated level
at current time point is based on recent
observations and some observations of
very distant past
the value of beta here is one and this
indicates that the slope b of the trend
component has been updated over the time
series
this results makes a good intuitive
result
so as the level changes over the time
series the slope b of the trend
component will happen to remain more or
less same
then we see that gamma is assigned a
value
of zero
this indicates that the estimate we have
of the seasonal component at the current
point of time is based upon very old
observations
hence this condition shows no
seasonality
now we will see what happens when beta
is equal to zero and gamma is made equal
to one
so type hw3 equals to holt winters of
log cola two
comma beta equals to zero comma gamma
equals to one
we can see the result showing holt
winter's exponential smoothing with
trend and additive seasonal component
the smoothing parameters here as we can
see in the result is alpha equals to
0.4307
beta equals to zero and gamma equals to
one
the value of alpha that we can see from
the result as 0.4307
is relatively low
this indicates that the estimated level
at current time point is based on recent
observations and some observations of
very distant past
the value of beta here is zero and this
indicates that the slope b of the trend
component has not been updated over the
time series
this is instead been set equal to zero
to its initial value
so as the level changes over the time
series
the slope b of the trend component will
happen to remain more or less same
contrasting to this situation we have
the gamma value that shows a very high
number that is 1.
this indicates that the estimate we have
of the seasonal component at the current
point of time is actually based upon a
very recent observation
this condition shows no trend
now we shall see what happens when both
beta and gamma are made to be equal to
zero
so type hw4 equals to holt winters of
log cola two
comma beta equals to zero comma gamma
equals to zero
we can see the result showing holt
winter's exponential smoothing with
trend and additive seasonal component
the smoothing parameters here as we can
see in the result is alpha equals to
0.2320
beta equals to zero and gamma equals to
zero
the value of alpha that we can see from
the result as
0.2320
is very low
this indicates that the estimated level
at current time point is based on very
few recent observations and most of the
observations are a very distant past
the value of beta here is zero and this
indicates that the slope b of the trend
component has not been updated over the
time series
this is instead been set equal to zero
to its initial value so as the level
changes over the time series the slope b
of the trend component will happen to
remain more or less same
we also have the gamma value which is
showing as 0.
this indicates that the estimate we have
of the seasonal component at the current
point of time
is based upon observation of distant
past
now let's make a plot of log cola 2
forecast
we can see from the plot that the holt
winter's exponential method has been
successful in predicting the seasonal
peaks
and these peaks and sales of cola are
occurring roughly during the end of the
year around november of every year
in the next slide we will look at white
noise
a stationary time series epsilon is said
to be white noise if correlation of
epsilon t
comma epsilon s equals zero for all t
not equal to s
epsilon t is a sequence of uncorrelated
random variables with constant variance
and constant mean
plots of white noise series exhibit a
very erratic jumpy and unpredictable
behavior
since the values of epsilon are
uncorrelated previous values do not help
us to forecast the future values
white noise series themselves are quite
uninteresting from a forecasting
standpoint
they are not linearly forecastable
but they form the building blocks for
more general models
in the next slide we will look at
corellogram
correlogram analysis is a tool used to
analyze how current data is correlated
to past data
it involves two functions
autocorrelation function
acf
and partial autocorrelation function
pacf
autocorrelation function of a time
series data x t
is defined by the correlation of current
value with the past values
mathematically acf of leg k for a
stationary time series is a ratio of the
covariance between the covariance of
present and past values
and the variance of the present value
partial autocorrelation function is an
extension of the concept in acf
acf finds the direct correlation but
pacf removes the direct effect caused by
the values x t
plus one
till x t plus k plus one
the mathematical formula for p a c f is
shown here for reference
however it is complex for a foundation
course so we will not get into the
details of p a c f
for k equals to 1 acf equals to pacf
in the next slide we will look at box
jenkins forecasting models
box jenkins forecasting models are based
on statistical concepts and principles
and are able to model a wide spectrum of
time series behavior
the box jenkins arma model is a
combination of the ar and ma models
the box jenkins model assumes that the
time series is stationary
box and jenkins recommend differencing
non-stationary series one or more times
to achieve stationarity
doing so produces an arma model with the
i standing for integrated
some formulations transform the series
by subtracting the mean of the series
from each data point
this yields a series with a mean of zero
the model can be extended to include
seasonal auto regression and seasonal
moving average terms
although this complicates the notation
the terms are similar to the
non-seasonal autoregressive and moving
average terms
the most general box jenkins model
different operators auto regressive
terms moving average terms seasonal
difference operators seasonal auto
regressive terms and seasonal moving
average terms
in the next slide we will look at the
primary stages in building the box
jenkins time series model
there are three primary stages in
building a box jenkins time series model
and they are
model identification
model estimation
model validation
box jenkins models are quite flexible
due to the inclusion of both auto
regressive and moving average terms
based on the wooled decomposition
theorem a stationary process can be
approximated by an arma model
in practice finding that approximation
may not be easy
building good arima models generally
requires more experience than commonly
used statistical methods such as
regression
in the next slide we will look at auto
regressive models in detail
the autoregressive ar
process models the conditional mean of r
as a function of past observations of y
an ar process that depends on p
past observations is called an ar model
of degree p denoted by ar
of p
a r model can be given by yt
equals to alpha
not plus beta 1 times yt
minus 1 plus beta
2 times yt
minus 2
up to beta p times y t
minus p plus e t
where e is a series of white noise alpha
not
beta 1
beta 2 up to beta p are coefficients
acf decays down to zero as lag increases
pacf is nonzero till k equals to p
for k greater than p
p a c f equals to zero
in the next slide we will look at a
moving average model
the moving average or m a model captures
serial autocorrelation in a time series
y
by expressing the conditional mean of y
as a function of past innovations
an m a model that depends on q
past innovations is called an m a model
of degree
q
denoted by
m a of q
m a model is shown here for reference
in reality
e t is not observed
so we estimate these by
z t
where z t equals to y t
bar
minus y t
so the m a of q model boils down to y t
equals to e t plus gamma one times z t
minus 1
plus gamma 2 times
zt
minus 2
plus up to gamma p
times zt
minus q
acf is non-zero till k equals to q
for k is greater than q
acf is zero
pacf decays down to zero as lag
increases
in the next slide we will look at auto
regressive moving average models
arma models are used in forecasting
stationary models
whose mean and variance remain constant
through time
i.e
no trend effect
for some observed time series a very
high order ar or ma model is needed to
model the underlying process well
in this case a combined auto regressive
moving average
arma model can sometimes be a more
parsimonious choice
an arma model expresses the conditional
mean of yt
as a function of both past observations
and past innovations
an arma of
p q
model is given by
yt equals to alpha
not
plus beta
1 times
yt minus 1 plus beta 2 times
yt
minus 2
up to beta p
times yt
minus p
plus gamma 1 times zt
plus gamma 2 times zt
minus 2
up to gamma p
z t
minus q plus e t
where p denotes ar order q denotes m a
order
in the next slide we will look at arima
models
auto regressive integrated moving
average or rmm models are a general
class of models for forecasting time
series of non-stationary models that can
be converted to stationary models using
logging or differentiating
the models include an explicit
statistical model for the irregular
component of a time series that allows
for non-zero auto correlations in the
irregular component
therefore if you start off with a
non-stationary time series you will
first need to
difference the time series until you
obtain a stationary time series
to difference the time series d times to
obtain a stationary series then there is
an arma
of p d q model where d is the order of
differencing used
to difference a time series using r use
the diff function
in the next slide we will continue
discussing the arima model
suppose we consider the yt series which
are known to be non-stationary
for yt we calculate
t as below
w t equals to y t
plus one
minus y t
equals to delta power one times y t
where wt is known as first order
difference of yt
now if we say wt follows arma of p
comma q
then we say
yt follow aroma of
p
comma one comma q
in general if we say yt follows arima of
order p
comma d comma q then
w t
equals to alpha
not plus beta one times wt
minus one plus beta two times wt
two plus up to
beta p times wt
minus p
plus gamma one times zt
minus one plus gamma two times zt
minus two plus up to gamma p times zt
minus q plus et
wt equals to delta d times
yt
and zt equals to wt bar minus wt
second order difference is given by
wt
equals to delta power
times yt equals to delta power one times
yt
plus one minus delta power one times yt
which equals to yt plus two minus yt
plus one minus yt plus one minus yt
in the next slide we will look at a
summary of the forecasting functions in
r
the table shows the different
forecasting functions in r and their
comparisons
we can see that a simple exponential
smoothing method has no trend or
seasonality
holt's method has trend component but
lacks seasonality
which is overcome in the holt winters
method
rmm models encompass a family of
functions and take all the components
into account
in the next video we will take up a time
series data and use the various
forecasting techniques that we have
learned so far
now we will look at a case study of time
series data and use the arima
holt's winter ets and linear regression
models to perform forecasting on the
data and compare their results
a chart paper manufacturing company has
its sales data of chart paper over a
period of four years
the data set contains two columns
the month of the year and the net sales
quantity in thousands
we use the read dot csv command and
specify the path of the file
and save it to a variable
say
my data
now type head of my data to check if the
data has been loaded properly
we have read the file and saved it to a
data frame in r
similar to the previous time series
example in r we will now convert the
data into a time series object
using the ts function
so type ts of
my data
dollar net sales quantity
comma
start equals c of 2010
comma four
frequency equals 12 and save it to a
variable named ts underscore my data
we saw from the first row that the data
starts from the april month of 2010
so we have given the start value as
2010 comma four
now we will type ts underscore my data
and we can see that we have a time
series data starting from april
we have used only the net sales quantity
variable and hence we have a univariate
time series data
now let us plot the data to get an
overall idea of the sales over the given
time period
so type plot of ts underscore my data
and press enter
the resulting plot has quite irregular
crests and troughs with especially two
peaks in sales sometime in mid 2012 and
mid 2013
so we can also note that the sales
gradually increases as the time
increases and thus the sales trend is
positive over time
now let us start with the forecasting
we will use most of the functions from
the forecast package in r
so we first install and add the forecast
package to the session since we have
already installed the package we will
type library of forecast and add the
package to the current working session
first we will use the arma model
the arma forecasting can be done using
the auto dot arma and arma functions
the auto dot arma function automatically
selects the arma model that best fits
the data according to a specified
information criterion
we will now type auto dot aurma of ts
underscore my data and save it to a
variable named model underscore arma
now to view the model type model
underscore arima
we see that arma of 0 comma 1
comma 1
and 1 comma 1
comma 0 has been used
the moving average and seasonal auto
regressive values are displayed
along with the sigma squared estimates
log likelihood and the information
criterion values
we will use the aic values later in this
case study to compare the different
models
the confidence interval can also be
displayed using the comp int function
by typing comp int of model underscore
aurima it displays the 2.5 percent and
97.5 percent confidence interval values
for the moving average and auto
regressive factors
now let us forecast using the model that
we just built
the forecast function can be used to get
a forecast by specifying the model name
and number of values to be forecasted
so we type forecast of model
underscore arma comma 20.
the result shows the forecasted value
the low and high eighty percent and
ninety five percent confidence interval
values for the months april two thousand
fourteen to november two thousand
fifteen
the plot function can be used along with
the forecast function to plot the
forecasted values
so we type plot of forecast of model
underscore aroma comma 20.
the dark gray area denotes the 80
confidence interval area and the lighter
gray denotes the 95 confidence interval
area
we can see that the forecasts are also
irregular with similar crests and
troughs as the original data
next we will perform an aurama using the
arma method
in the arma function we manually specify
the number of auto-regressive terms the
order of differentiation and the number
of moving average terms
the most commonly used aurama model is
the arma of
0 comma 1 comma 1
and 0 comma 1 comma one model
it is a seasonal random trend model that
is fine-tuned by the addition of a
moving average in auto regressive terms
to specify the model as we saw in the
slide we type arma
of ts underscore my data comma order
equals c of 0 comma 1 comma 1.
to add seasonality we use the
seasonality attribute and assign it to
list of order of c equals zero comma one
comma one
we save this model to a variable named
model underscore m arma
and now type model underscore m arma and
see the results
you can note that the results are almost
similar to the auto dot arma values and
the aic value is also almost equal
for the next step we forecast the next
20 values by typing forecast of model
underscore m arma comma 20.
as before the forecast 80 percent and 95
confidence interval values are displayed
next we plot the forecasted values by
typing plot of forecast of model
underscore m arma comma 20.
the results of auto dot aurma and the
seasonal random trend model are almost
similar
except that the auto dot arima model has
more smoothened forecasts
the fluctuations that are shown in the
srt model towards the end of 2015 is
absent in the auto dot arma model and is
more smoothened
for the next method we will choose the
ets method
the ets method implements an automated
smoothing model on the given time series
data
we type ets of ts underscore my data and
store it to a variable model
underscore ets
now we type model underscore ets to view
the results
you can note that the results are
different from the arma models
here we get the smoothing parameters
alpha beta and gamma
corresponding to the data trend and
seasonal smoothing components
the ets model that has been chosen is
the
m
comma a comma m model
which refers to a multiplicative error
additive trend and multiplicitive
seasonality model
next we do the forecasting by typing
forecast of model underscore ets comma
20 and obtain similar results with the
point in confidence interval values
now we can plot the forecasted values by
typing plot of forecast of model
underscore ets comma 20.
it is interesting to note that in ets
forecasting the trend for the forecasted
values decreases or remain almost
constant as opposed to the arima models
where it was an increasing fashion
the fourth model we will use is the holt
winters method
as we already know
we will use the holt winters method on
data that contains seasonality as well
here we type holt winters of ts
underscore my data and save it to a
variable named model underscore hw
now on typing model h underscore hw
we obtain the results
the method uses a trend and additive
seasonal component and the alpha beta
and gamma values are displayed
comparing with the previous alpha values
we can see that they are significantly
different from each other
the coefficients show the values for
each of the seasons from s1 to s12
as earlier we will now make a forecast
by typing forecasts of model underscore
hw
comma 20 and obtain the point in
confidence interval forecasted values
next we plot the values by typing plot
of forecast of model underscore hw comma
20.
this plot looks similar to the ets plot
trend wise however the 80 percent and 95
percent confidence interval values are
far more wider and pronounced
finally we will use the linear
regression model
just to recap we know that the previous
models we have discussed so far are
forecasting time series models
whereas linear regression is more of a
cause and effect model
the tslm function of the forecast
package is used to fit linear regression
models on time series data
since it is a univariate data the
formula will be given with the dependent
value as time series data and the
independent values as seasonality and
trend
here we type tslm of ts underscore my
data
tilde trend plus season and store it in
a variable named model underscore tslm
now typing model underscore tslm we
obtain the results
the results are similar to a linear
regression model
here the dependent variables are the
trend and the season values
since it is monthly data the season
values vary from season 2 to season 12.
since season is almost a categorical
variable taking one of 12 values the
coefficients are calculated for 12 minus
that is 11 values
we will now forecast by typing forecast
of model underscore tslm comma
n equals 20 to obtain the predicted
values
a plot of the predicted values given by
plot of forecast of model underscore
tslm
comma
h equals 20 gives us a very different
plot from the earlier ones
the trend increases visibly in this plot
another stark contrast between
forecasting and cause and effect models
are that in forecasting models the
current value is quite dependent on the
immediately previous value and hence you
will note that the forecasted values
almost continue from the previous value
however
in linear regression the values are
fitted through a line and thus there is
no continuity as you can see from the
plot
now let us view the different plots
together to get an overall idea
we will use the split dot screen
function to split the graphical output
we type split dot screen of figs equals
c of two
to specify the number of rows and
columns as two
we will display only four plots here for
the sake of comparisons
since the auto dot arima and arama
models are almost similar we will only
use the auto dot arima model here
now to plot the different sections first
type screen of one and we plot the auto
dot arma model
next we type screen of two and plot the
ets model
the third section is plotted by typing
screen of three and plotting the holt
winters model
finally we type screen of four and plot
the linear regression model
we can now view all the four plots side
by side
the ets and holt winters models have
wider confidence intervals with time
whereas for the auto dot rma and linear
regression models the confidence
intervals remain almost constant
except for ets
all of the other models have an
increasing constant trend
however even though we have a comparison
of the forecasts we do not know which
models fits the best
to check this we use the aic criterion
the aic criterion for the models are
listed
and the relative probability of
minimizing information loss is found by
exponential comparisons of the values
for the sake of simplicity in this case
study we can note that the model with
the lowest aic value has the lowest
information loss
the aic function can be used with the
different model names as attributes to
display their corresponding aic values
if we give all five model names as
attributes we get an error that the
method cannot be used for holt winters
since holt winters does not use the
maximum likelihood function
so we remove halt winters and compare
the other four functions
we can see that the arma models have the
lowest aic values
and hence they are best suited for our
data set
this video completes a comprehensive
study of time series analysis and
forecasting techniques
in the next video we will look at a case
study in which we will implement all the
concepts we have learned so far in this
course
now that we have covered the
fundamentals of analytics course through
r let us take a business case where some
of the concepts learned from lesson one
to now make it used
the intention here is to give the way in
which a business problem is typically
solved
in our business case we have a retail
company who wants to derive values from
their point of sale data across
different stores
there are two data sets
one which contains product category and
the other contains the details of 500
gram packets of broccoli
broccoli is a product from one of the
categories of data
point of sale data is data which is
captured at each store and covers the
billing process for the product sold
it does not give any detailed
information about the customers
themselves but a lot of useful
information about products can come out
from the data as we will see going
further in the case
first step as usual would be to load the
data from the data set given
so we upload the data from the read dot
csv function
we name the two data sets as cat data
and the other as broccoli as shown here
we will do a descriptive analysis on the
first data set cat data
we first check out the metadata by using
the head function
the data is for five product categories
namely kitchen grains pulses
vegetables and merchandise
the numbers are the quantity sold of
each type
next we see the complete data set
the data is for 66 weeks starting from
december 30th 2012 and ending march 30th
2014.
we need to first understand the data and
start to work over
going back to category wise data let us
draw scatter plot understanding and
quantity sold for each category across
timelines
we attach the cat data and then define a
variable called y range
which will set limit for y as we are
going to draw scatter plots of
categories on the same axis
we then plot the kitchen quantity
next we add scatter lines for all the
product categories
this is done with the lines function
you can always go back to the lessons
for revision
the scatter plot shows that pulses and
kitchen items are sold less compared to
others but there are no fluctuations and
are sold uniformly
merchandise sales quantity increases and
decreases randomly and there seems to be
no pattern in crests and troughs
grains are the highest selling category
and had fluctuations where there seems
to be a pattern
similar is the case with the vegetable
category
now let us summarize the data
we summarize each of the categories
together so what do we observe
same as in the scatter chart merchandise
has the highest standard deviation and
hence so much fluctuation
grains pulses and vegetables are
negatively skewed whereas kitchen and
merchandise are positively skewed
the range of pulses is the minimum
and also the standard deviation is
lowest which signifies that demand for
pulses is uniform throughout the year
and does not very much
after understanding the descriptive part
of the variables we will look into the
diagnostic part of analytics
this part will answer any relationship
we have among independent variables or
between dependent and independent
variables
we want to do a correlation between the
sales quantities for each of the product
category
why did we choose correlation and not
chi-square test
because the values of each of the
variables here are continuous numerical
and non-categorical
to do the correlation we need to remove
the weak column in the data set as
correlation can only be performed on
numerical data
so we reduce that column and name the
new data set as
core
underscore cat data and then perform
correlation
so what do we see in the results
looking at all the values from 0 to 1 we
see interesting observations
grains and vegetables have a correlation
of 0.9
meaning the demand quantities follow
each other and have similar patterns
even pulses and vegetables have a
correlation of
0.77
again the demand quantities of
vegetables and pulses follow each other
but to a lesser extent than between
grains and vegetables
all the values are positive and none of
them negative
all the demand quantities are positively
related to each other none of the
categories affect the other negatively
or cannibalize the demand
what it also implies is that if we
predict the demand of vegetables and get
a working model the same model may work
to predict the demand of grains to a
large extent and pulses to a smaller
extent
let us now have a look at the broccoli
data
what we know is that data is for
broccoli 500 gram packets sold across
outlets in a particular city
rainfall gives the value in centimeter
for the particular city across time
season column gives a value of one for
winters and zero for other seasons
winter is assumed from november to
february
we do the same as with category data we
first check out the metadata by using
the head function
we see quantity rate year week rainfall
and season
rate is the price of broccoli across
different weeks
we will now do some descriptive analysis
on the data set
as done earlier we will perform the
summary function on the data set
broccoli
so what do we observe from the summary
the average rate or price of broccoli
does not change much throughout the time
period given and has a range of 20
approximately with minimum price being
77 and maximum 97.
the season value confirms our definition
of being either zero or one
the mean rainfall is low around 2.3
centimeters with a maximum of 22.2
centimeters telling us that rainfall
throughout the year is very low except
during some periods
we will now perform a correlation for
this data set to understand the
relationship among variables
as done earlier we will apply the
correlation function on the data set
what we observe is
average rate related negatively with the
demand quantity
seasonality or winter has almost no
effect on demand quantity and if it has
then negatively
rainfall has almost no effect on demand
quantity and if it has then negatively
we should be careful again with
correlation and not conclude that these
factors are causing the demand to go up
and down but at least we now know demand
is related to all the factors
if we want we can also see the
correlations in r using the pairs
function
it shows us graphs for correlation
quantity on top is the y-axis for the
four graphs and all the other variables
are x-axis respectively
the slope of the line gives us an idea
graphically
to give an example let us take the
average rate as y-axis
and year week as x-axis
the slope is positive meaning average
rate and year week are positively
related
if we check the correlation matrix the
correlation value is 0.4
which justifies the plot
we can also see the direction of
relation again by doing a covariance on
the data
now that we are done with understanding
the data set given we will move on to
predicting demand
understanding the factors affecting
demand through time series models linear
regression etc
as we have already concluded that
predicting the vegetable category demand
may give us some answers we will start
with predicting it
just to reiterate the rationale behind
choosing it first is its pattern will
tell us about the pulses as well as
grains
also since the standard deviation is low
it is easy to predict compared to others
first we create a data set separately
for vegetable from the overall data set
doing the aforementioned manipulation we
name the data set as veg underscore cat
data
then we do a summary of the data before
predicting
the first quartile is 57270
mean value is sixty thousand one hundred
twenty and the minimum value is fifteen
thousand six hundred sixty
now we look at the data set again
fifteen thousand five hundred sixty
seems like an outlier considering the
quartile and mean value
so we remove it from our data set
we do it using which condition to filter
out the unwanted value of fifteen
thousand six hundred sixty
next we create a time series data series
from the data given as taught earlier
and we name it as ts underscore veg
underscore cat data
the time series has been defined on the
basis of the data given
frequency 52 signifies that the data
given is weekly and hence 52 weeks
completes a year on the timeline
we are going to use the forecast package
we have already discussed the
dependencies of installing this package
in an example earlier
we first use the holt winter's function
to get a fit
this gives us an error saying
seasonality cannot be taken here
try yourself to find out why this is
happening
so now we take away the season factor
from holt's winter by putting gamma
equals false
and get a fit which is named as fit
underscore hw
we now plot this fit and see the graph
the fit seems fine but we will check out
the accuracy mathematically later
let us now try simple moving average for
this data set
we use the m a function in the forecast
package for doing this
in this case first we plot the original
time series data set
then we fit a moving average with the
order of smoothing as three
that is the last three weeks are
considered for taking the moving average
next we use the function lines to add
the plot already created
we also provide the line with blue color
to distinguish from the original plot
now let us increase the order to six
weeks and see the effects
we again create a fit specifically for
six months and name it as fit
underscore m a
underscore six
and use the line function again to add a
green line
what do we observe
in this case visually we see that some
points where there are rises and falls
the fitted value seems more flattened
out as compared to three weeks also it
seems three weeks moving average may be
a better fit than a six-week moving
average
next we use linear regression for taking
into account the trend and seasonality
of the data set provided
we use the tslm function to achieve it
as done earlier we first plot the time
series data
we then define the fit named as fit
underscore lm
we then add the lines to the existing
plot and look at the new fit graphically
we now have four fits from three
different methods there are other
methods too such as ets erima which we
have not used and you should try
yourself
but how do we decide which fit is the
best
surely not just by looking at these
plots we have a function called accuracy
function which will give us the error
for all our fits
so we apply the function for the four
fits
what do we see
there are various errors which are given
and as of now for the scope of the
course we will just talk about mean
error
mean absolute error and root mean square
for the moving average case three weeks
moving average seems a better fit than
six weeks as all the three errors we are
looking at is less in case of three
weeks
worst of the lot is halt winter's method
with the highest mean error
mean absolute error and root mean square
error and hence is rejected for
consideration
only linear regression fit and
three-week moving average seems to give
a better estimate of the actual values
the mean error is least for linear
regression fit but the root mean square
error is greater than for the three week
moving average
for prediction through linear regression
forecast function is used the mean error
is least for linear regression fit but
the root mean square error is greater
than for three week moving average
for prediction through linear regression
forecast function is used we also need
to give the value of the periods for
which to forecast
in our case let us give 20 weeks
the plot is then made for the forecasted
values
so from the category data set we derived
useful information and even forecasted
the demand of vegetables
let us try to do some analysis of the
broccoli data set
moving on to the broccoli data set we
need to understand how each of the
factors affects the demand quantity we
will perform multiple linear regression
on the data set in r
we first attach the data set broccoli
then we use the lm function as taught
already
here our target variable is quantity and
the independent variables are average
rate
year week rainfall and season
we then summarize the fit and understand
the details
r square value is low
which is the case for many practical
cases
look at how each of the factors affects
the demand quantity and the p
values intercept of the line has a
p-value lesser than
0.001 and hence it becomes significant
in our model
p-values for season and rainfall are way
higher than the significant level
hence they practically have no effect on
demand quantity of broccoli
this is in absolute alignment with what
we found out in correlation of this data
set
you can always go back and match the
results
the p-value for year week is higher than
the significant value but not very high
so we can consider it if we want
the p-value for average rate is again
lower than point zero zero one
and hence is the most important factor
for broccoli
also it's negatively affecting the sales
quantity again tying with correlation
results
a business perspective it means that if
the store increases the price of
broccoli the sales quantity will come
down
next we want to see if there is any
interaction between season and rainfall
and whether it improves the adjusted r
square
from doing the process again but this
time also including interaction we find
the adjusted r square reduces
now let us again make a linear
regression model removing seasonality
and rainfall
this time we only consider average rate
and year week
you can also plot the fit
but before that you need to split your r
graphics window into two rows and
columns as there are four plots which
get generated
we are not going too much into the
technicality of each plot
what we should know is that this
regression model can also now be used to
predict the sales quantity of broccoli
sold
let's say the price of broccoli suddenly
jumps to one hundred from eighty
then what would happen to demand
through linear regression we can
calculate that demand and be ready to
align our decisions accordingly
of course the linear regression model we
have come up with needs to be improved
the r square value of 28
tells us that there are many other
factors affecting the sales of broccoli
these factors need to be considered or
added
once we have those factors the
prediction will become even more
accurate
but with the current information
provided by the retail company the best
model to predict the demand is the
regression model derived
we can use various other models with the
same data set starting from time series
models such as ets
aroma etc
or cause and effect model such as
multivariate linear regression etc
some of these models have been taught
earlier and we encourage you to use
these models on the broccoli data set
here is a quick recap of what we have
learned in this lesson
regression analysis
types of regression models
simple linear regression
logistic regression
building regression models
cluster analysis
types of clustering
types of clusters
methods to form clusters
time series analysis
components of time series
decomposition of time series seasonal
and non-seasonal
exponential smoothing
white noise
corellogram
box jenkins
arima
with this we come to the end of the
business analytics foundation with our
tools course offered by simpler learn
thank you and happy learning